>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Well good morning again and
welcome to the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole, I'm the Director
of the Center for the Book
in the Library of Congress.
Thanks for coming to our
very special Books and Beyond
for Young People's program.
Our Center for the Book promotes
books, reading, libraries
and literacy to people of all ages
nationwide and here at the library,
we have a room well,
actually three rooms
for those under 16 years of age.
It's called the Young Reader's
Center, opened in 2009.
The center is on the ground floor
of this beautiful Jefferson Building
and there, with a parent or a
guardian, you can attend one
of our many programs or read the
latest books for young people.
This morning I want to acknowledge
the Yount Reader Center Head,
Karen Jaffe who with her staff
and volunteers have organized
this wonderful program.
Karen, please stand up.
Let's give her a hand.
[ Applause ]
>> This actually is an annual
program for the Center for the Book
and its Young Reader's Center.
It's called The Jonah
Solkoff Eskin Memorial Program
and it has been funded for seven
years by Barney and Marsha Eskin
who are here with their son, Lee.
Please, I would like these
three wonderful people to stand
and be acknowledged by our crowd.
[ Applause ]
>> And in addition, here
at the Library of Congress,
we love to add more resources
from our wonderful programs.
Today, another sponsor is the
library's Veteran History Project,
which collects, preserves, and
makes accessible the war stories
of America's Veterans.
This project accepts Veteran's
recorded oral histories as well
as the collections of
original photographs, letters,
military documents, diaries,
maps and other written materials.
Any student over 15 can
participate by asking an adult,
or an older sibling or friend to
join you in interviewing a Veteran.
You might know a Veteran from
your own family, neighborhood,
or even a school whom you can
invite to participate with you
in this important project.
You can visit the Library
of Congress website
for more information.
But let me tell you
about today's audience.
We don't have time for our usual
school by school cheerleading
so please hold your applause
until I go through the list.
Representing the military is Joint
Base Fort Myer-Henderson Hall
in Virginia and Joint Base Andrews
Naval Air Facility in Maryland.
Both have brought military families,
home schooled students
and Girl Scouts.
Schools represented from
the District of Columbia,
Washington School for Girls,
Stuart-Hobson Middle School
and Richard Wright
Charter Public School.
From Virginia is Osbourn
Park High School.
We also have representatives from
the Stonewall Jackson High School,
Prince William County Public Schools
and Arlington County Public Schools.
Let's have a round of applause for
all of our students, their teachers-
[ Applause ]
>> And we also thank their
chaperones and parents.
It is now my pleasure
to introduce David Mao,
who is the Acting Librarian
of Congress.
For you kids, that means he's
a big shot okay [laughter].
David oversees the entire library
and its various service units
to insure the library's
services to Congress
and to the entire American
people are provided effectively.
He previously served as
Deputy Librarian of Congress
and as the 23rd Law
Librarian of Congress.
Please welcome David Mao.
David?
[ Applause ]
>> Hi.
>> Thank you very much John
and good morning to all of you.
Welcome to the Library of Congress
on this 72nd Anniversary of D-Day.
Today's program was inspired
by Michael Grant's recent book,
Front Lines, and it gives
us an opportunity to talk
about imagined roles of women in
the military during World War II
and also gives us an opportunity to
compare the events of World War II
with 21st century military life.
Now, Front Lines the book is the
first in a planned trilogy of books.
Mr. Grant is also the
author of the Gone series
and the Magnificent Twelve series
and he spent much of
his life on the move.
He was raised in a miliary
family and as I understand it,
spent his years in 13 different
schools in five different states
and Europe so quite a
lot of moving around.
His Front Lines book
imagines a World War II
with enlisted service
members of both genders
and it specifically chronicles three
young women of diverse backgrounds
who are placed in combat alongside
of their male counterparts
so Michael, thank you very much
for joining us today
to discuss your book.
I want to introduce the other
guests but before I do that,
I want to ask you to read a
short passage from Front Lines
so that we can set the stage
for today's discussion.
>> Should we do that now?
>> Yup, cool.
You can sit there.
>> Oh excellent, so much easier.
I'll just stretch out here.
I've chosen a passage that's only I
think about 78 pages long [laughter]
so it shouldn't be a problem.
Where we are right now is that one
of our main characters
Rio has been dragged along
on a mission that's not going to go
very well but it involves a landing
on a beach and this is her first
time in any kind of serious trouble
and they're jumping off
the boat right then.
"Rio lurches to her right.
Three steps, four, five, ten,
fifteen, counting them off,
drops to her knees, plants the
butt of her rifle and lies face
down on her belly with the
weapon pointing towards
where she thinks the
machine gunner might be.
Fifteen hundred rounds per minute,
the standard German machine gun
fires fifteen hundred rounds
per minute.
The machine gun opens up again,
loud but distant followed by softer
but way too near pff pff
sounds as the bullets hit sand.
Soft whimpering noises are
coming from her throat,
unlike any sound she's
ever made before.
A split second slower than
Rio had hit the ground,
Kerwin [phonetic] cries out.
He says, "Oh."
Just that, "Oh."
Rio sees him fall backwards.
His head lands in the edge
of retreating foam,
legs folded beneath him.
"Castle, you hit?"
No answer.
"God no, God no, God no."
The Jeep roars and splashes
out of the landing craft
and instantly draws the fire
of the enemy machine gun.
"Are you hit?
Castle, are you hit?"
"Doc? Doc?"
someone yells.
The Jeep swerves left and goes nose
down in a hole, rear wheels spinning
and throwing up a plume of sand.
"Richlin, give doc a hand with
Castle", Sergeant Cole yells.
"Stick, get that BAR up
onto that dune there.
Put some fire on that machine gun.
Take gear with you.
Castain, Pang, Suarez [assumed
spellings], stay low and follow me."
Rio crawls towards her stricken
comrade, elbows digging,
knees pushing, heart gone mad.
The doc who came to shore with
fourth squad is hunched over Castle.
He grabs at something in his
medical kit and now Rio sees
that Castle is flailing
spasmodically,
arms and legs jerking,
torso heaving.
An advancing wave covers
his face and foam.
"Pull him back, pull him back,
pull him back God damn it!
He'll drown" the medic shouts.
Rio grabs Castles legs and
has to rise to her own knees
in order to get leverage.
She is acutely aware of her exposed
back but hauls him out of the surf.
"Hold him down" the medic
says through gritted teeth,
as he tears open a bandage.
"Gotta stop the bleeding, his neck."
"Take it easy Castle,
take it easy" Rio says.
Blood pulses from Castle's throat
like a garden hose
someone is kinking
and releasing, kinking
and releasing.
The blood looks like chocolate
syrup in the darkness.
Kerwin is making guttural sounds,
words full of urgency
with no vowels.
Rio rises again just high enough to
place her hands on Kerwin's chest
and hold him down but as she does
this she feels slippery warmth
and realizes that large quantities
of blood are gushing
from his upper chest.
He's been hit twice, not once.
"Gotta take it easy, Castle.
Let doc work."
It wound sound better if my
teeth weren't chattering,
but Kerwin isn't hearing her.
He jerks wildly, tries to
say something that comes
out as a plaintive grunt,
then lays back down quieting.
Doc slaps a pressure
bandage on but the artery
in Castle's neck has barely slowed.
It's like trying to block a
fire hydrant with your fingers.
Doc rips Castle's uniform shirt open
and there's a second hole
near, too near to his heart.
The medic curses and then
covers that by telling Castle,
"It's okay, it's okay soldier.
You'll be okay.
Going home is all, going home."
It's a lie, but Kerwin
never hears it anyway.
Rio feels his heart stop.
One second there's a wild beating
thing in his chest, then nothing.
Kerwin's last breath was a
slow, wet, wheeze of exhalation
as if he's sinking back into
an easy chair after a long day.
The machine gun shatters
and digs divots pff pff pff
in the sand near Rio so she has
to roll away clutching her rifle
to her chest with blood
slicked hands.
Kerwin is dead without ever
getting a chance to speak.
His final intelligible word was
just that single syllable, "Oh."
[ Applause ]
>> So that was cheerful [laughter].
>> Well thank you for that
very descriptive reading,
thank you so much.
We're also very privileged
today to have joining us
for today's discussion
Lieutenant Commander Kristen Hansen
and Captain Rebecca Murga.
[ Applause ]
>> Lieutenant Commander
Hansen is a graduate
of the United States Naval Academy.
She made her first deployment to
Iraq and Afghanistan in support
of Operation Iraqi Freedom and then
joined Operation Enduring Freedom.
After graduating from Navy Fighter
Weapon School, yes that's Top Gun,
she became a strike
fighter tactics instructor.
Commander Hansen, to her credit,
has 66 combat sorties over Iraq,
Afghanistan and Syria
and 472 carrier landings.
As a Public Affairs Officer,
Captain Murga has captured
the soldier's story in combat.
She was attached to a special
operations command supporting SEAL
teams and Special Forces
in Afghanistan.
She received the Bronze
Star for her service
and the Meritorious Service
Medal for service in Iraq.
Currently, she's Captain in the
Office of Chief Army Reserve.
Thank you both very
much for your service
to our country and
for your sacrifices.
[ Applause ]
>> Our very special guest
today is Dr. Jill Biden.
She knows sacrifice as well and
Dr. Biden, we are very proud
that you are joining us and
you are a Blue Star Mom,
so thank you for being here.
Military families founded Blue Star
Families to support one another
and to enlist the community in
supporting military families.
As Second Lady, Dr. Biden
works to bring attention
to the sacrifices made by
military families as part
of her Joining Forces
initiative with Michelle Obama.
Dr. Biden also works tirelessly
to highlight the importance
of community colleges
in America's future.
She's a lifelong educator
and continues to teach
at a community college
in northern Virginia.
Among her many accomplishments,
Dr. Biden co-founded the
Book Buddies program,
which enlists trained
volunteers to provide instruction
to young students who need
extra support in literacy,
something that's very near
and dear to our heart here
at the Library of Congress.
Dr. Biden is also the author of
Don't Forget, God Bless Our Troops.
Today's program will offer insights
into the unique relationship
between literature and
history and we're very honored
to have her facilitate
this conversation.
At the end of the program, we'll
have time for questions and answers
and it will be followed by a
book signing with both Dr. Biden
and Mr. Grant, so enjoy the program.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so again, my name is
Jill Biden, I am a military mom.
Our son Beau was deployed
to Iraq for a year in 2008,
and one of the things that I've
spent the last eight years doing is
traveling the United States
and really around the world
and meeting with military families.
We've gone to bases in
Germany, and in Japan,
and all over the United States and
one of the focuses that we've had is
to talk really to women
in the military
and to see what their lives are
like and whether they're a spouse
or whether they're a fire
pilot, or on the front lines,
that's been our focus to see how
we can help military families.
Michelle and I have spent
really the last eight years
of this administration
working on that subject.
How many people in the
audience are a family
who is connected to the military?
Wow! A lot of you.
Great, so this is perfect
[laughter].
Today, we have two really special
women here because if you think
about it, how many, I guess kids
actually have their moms deployed?
It's hard to see because
the lights are in our eyes
so nobody really has a mom
deployed well, some of the moms
that I've met have told me really
if you think about all of you think
about your mom being deployed and
what you would kind of miss right?
Because the moms tell me, the moms
who are in the military service,
they tell me how hard it
is for them to be away
on those special occasions like
when their son or daughter is going
to college, or they
missed their graduation,
their high school graduation or
being there for special birthdays
or all kinds of special events.
So, if you think about that event
and not having your mom there
and having your mom in Iraq or
Afghanistan it's kind of hard
so you can see it from
both points of view.
You can see how the moms
are missing their children
and the children are missing their
mothers so this is truly a sacrifice
that I think female military leaders
make when they join the service.
Has anyone here in the
audience, has anyone thought
about joining the military?
Okay, a couple, all right.
As you've meet Kristen
and you've met Jessica-
>> Rebecca.
>> Rebecca-
>> I'll be Jessica
for you thought ma'am.
>> Okay [laughter], I'm
sorry so I'd like for them
to tell you their stories and
why they went into the military,
and what kind of jobs they do,
and you'll see really how
special they are so Kristen,
do you want to start with yours?
>> Sure, hi everybody, I'm Kristen.
I grew up in Weymouth, Massachusetts
which is about 30 minutes south
of Boston and for as
long as I can remember,
I grew up wanting to
be an astronaut.
I was upset when I
went to kindergarten
because I could not
watch shuttle launches
so my poor parents thought
I would grow out of it
and I never did, to their dismay.
But when I grew up I was like
well, I have to join the Air Force,
that's what astronauts
did and come to find
out the Naval Academy has the most
astronaut graduates in the country
so I was very binary and I was
like well, I'm going there.
And dad drove me down to Annapolis
and I was totally smitten.
I loved everything about it
and my mom was totally dismayed
when I came back and realized I
wasn't going to change my mind
so went to Navy, had an awesome
time there, played soccer,
studied aerospace engineering.
When I graduated, I was lucky
enough to select aviation,
went to flight school down
in Pensacola and Meridian
and was lucky enough to get
F18s out of flight school.
I got sent over to
Lemoore, California which is
about 45 minutes south of Fresno and
I have somehow managed to live there
for just over a decade now,
which is probably a world record
in the military, not having to move.
I've done three operational
tours over there
and an instructor tour
and had a fabulous time.
As they said, I've
done a couple of trips
over to the Gulf and to Afghanistan.
We actually just got home a year
ago with my current squadron
so it's been a fabulous
experience for me.
The people have been outstanding and
I get a somewhat expensive aircraft
to fly around on the
government's dime so thanks
to all the taxpayers [laughter],
I really appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
>> That's pretty impressive
really, to think of all the things
that you've done and the
career path that you've chosen.
So will you be deployed again?
>> Probably.
I think I probably have about one
more operational tour so I'm going
to an instructional tour for about
two and a half years in November
and then rotate out of
there and go back to sea
for about a 30 month tour and then
I'll be right about the time I have
to decide if I want to get
out or stay in so we'll see.
I have at least seven more years
before I have to grow up I guess.
>> All right, Rebecca, do you
want to tell us your story?
>> Sure, I'm originally
from Chicago, Illinois.
Anybody from Chicago in here?
Probably not.
>> Wait a minute, one person.
It's hard to see.
>> So, when I was a kid I
actually wanted to be a filmmaker.
I went in to watch a film called
Annie, and I left and told my mom,
" I want to be Annie" and she
said, "Well, you have parents,
you cannot be an orphan"
[laughter] and so I realized
that I wanted to make films.
And so, I went to school and
studied television production
and I was a senior in college
going that route when 9/11 happened
and for me, I just really
wanted to serve and give back
so I joined the Army,
which is the best branch
in case you don't know [laughter].
>> How many years have
we won in football?
>> I know, I know, not a good
football team but a fun branch.
So when I was in, at the time
my civilian job was working
in sports production so
I was working for ESPN
and Comcast doing some really
cool, fun things with the Yankees,
and when I deployed the Army
found out and they were like well,
you're going to tell
soldier stories now
so it was an incredible experience
because I spent about three years
between Iraq, Afghanistan,
and Kuwait traveling around
and interviewing soldiers
and videotaping them
and basically telling the American
public what these men and women did.
And in 2011, at that time I was one
of the first women to get attached
to Navy Seals and Special
Forces and Navy Seals (Navy)
in case you don't know, are some
of the most awesome folks out there
and Special Forces as well.
And women, at the time
of Afghanistan,
nobody had talked to them.
Nobody knew what they were
doing or how they were working
so what they did is they took a
bunch of women in the military,
they put them with the Navy Seals
and basically our job was to go out
and talk to these women,
and talk to children,
and find out what they were doing
because as most people know,
the status that women have in a
country is directly correlated
on how well that country
does economically,
how well it does socially, so
that was a big part of what I did.
And while I was over there, I
remember I was in the middle
of Afghanistan and a buddy of
mine said to me, "You know,
if you could do one
thing for the rest
of your life what would that be?"
And I said, "I want to make
films" and that's what I did.
He said you survived two years
in the middle of a war zone,
how hard can being a filmmaker be?
He had obviously never been to
Hollywood [laughter] so I went
to Los Angeles and spent the
last three years making films
and I'm finishing up a short
film that is going to be
on HBO probably next
fall, which is really cool
and it's basically telling
stories about that film
about a wounded warrior
who comes back
and so I realized my calling
now is really telling some
of those stories.
>> Congratulations.
>> What's the title?
>> It's called, One Halloween,
which is a very short film
about 15 minutes but we had 25
Veterans come and work on the set
and a couple Vets here actually
supporting me that were on that set.
I've got to give a
shout out to them.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi, welcome.
>> And it's great because as you
know, when you serve and you're
in the military, you're part
of a family and when you leave,
sometimes it's hard because
that family's not there anymore
but you do have organizations like
Veterans in Film and Television
that you support one another and
you tell the stories and I realize
that that's what I want to do
so my experience being
deployed has really prepped me
for the challenges of
Hollywood, I guess.
>> I bet it has.
Well you've really led an
interesting life as well.
>> Well I think, someone once said
something, it's not at the end
of your life it's not the person
with the most money that wins,
it's the person that
has the best stories
and so spend your life trying
to make really good
stories in your life.
>> Well, I think that's important
that the kids in the audience,
all the students in the
audience hear your stories
because I don't know what
perceptions they have of women
in the military, which is kind of
interesting Michael for you that one
of the things I wanted to know,
how did you choose this topic?
>> Well, I never believe in a
single motivation for everything
so there's always multiple motives
and part of it was marketing,
part of it was I like
history, and I'm frustrated
with the way history is taught and
I care about it and I care about it
as only a high school dropout
who came late to it can.
>> Oh, you dropped
out of high school?
>> Oh yeah-
[ Laughter ]
>> Remember their inspirational
stories [laughter]?
Nothing like that.
>> Did you get your GED?
>> Yeah, I did get a GED yes,
because I'm very good
at taking tests.
Then I went to college and
I dropped out of college.
[ Laughter ]
>> Wait a minute, I teach
college, stay in college,
stay in school [laughter].
>> I tell everybody, one of
my stablemates where I work,
the publisher I work for is
Veronica Roth, who did Divergent
and Veronica came right
out of college at like,
age 22 or whatever and
wrote a best-seller.
Do it her way and not mine.
If you're looking for a role
model, go for Ms. Roth and not me.
That was part of it.
Mostly to me, the threshold is am
I going to have fun doing this,
which sounds, I know I'm
supposed to have some grand motive
and some big long explanation
but honestly,
it was interesting in
terms of marketing.
We were trying to see
whether this kind of thing,
whether you could do old
history in the young adult,
whether that was going
to be a thing,
so I told my editor
I'm putting a bet
down on this, let's
see if this works.
We'll see how that goes.
But mostly, I was interested
in history
and I'd started reading The
Liberation Trilogy by Rick Atkinson
because my father in law had
forced it on me and I thought man,
I don't want another
book about World War II,
and I started reading it and about
halfway through I'm just like,
this is like so much story you know?
Almost like story as a commodity
like, thousands of pounds worth
of story and so I wanted
to kind of get into it
and I thought I can do that,
I can make it more interesting,
more accessible maybe.
I'll add a couple changes.
I made two big changes
in Front Lines,
one is by inventing a 1940
Supreme Court decision, which is-
>> Do you want to tell
them what that was?
>> Yeah, in my fictional
world in 1940,
the Supreme Court decision
comes down that opens the draft
and enlistment to women so
it's a big shock to society
but then this all happens
before Pearl Harbor and then
at Pearl Harbor, at the point
where the book starts society
and individuals are really confused
about what this is going to mean,
whether it's really going to happen.
The girls who enlist don't
actually expect to end up in combat,
they think they're probably
going to end up as secretaries
or driving trucks maybe so they're
a little shocked that they end
up on the front lines, which I
expect a lot of male soldiers-
>> Or nurses probably, stereotypes.
>> Yeah, the stereotypical jobs,
so I thought that was interesting
and I thought it would be fun
to write and also give me lots
of excuses to do travel that I could
write off on my taxes [laughter].
>> He's irreverent, isn't he?
>> Always a consideration, I'm going
to Europe this summer to research.
I just want to jump in and
say when they first asked me
to do this panel, I thought it
was me and some kid book writers.
There's one kid book writer here
but she's also Dr. Jill [laughter]
and then weeks later they go,
oh and Jill Biden will be there.
I go, "What?
What? Back up."
But I thought no, that's
fine, I'm used to academics.
And then they tell me that two
actual combat officers are going
to be there and I was right on
the edge of going I can't do this
because I make stuff up,
they do things [laughter].
Big gap between make stuff
up in the comfort of my home
and actually going out and being
in trouble in dangerous areas
so if you have questions, I guess
we're going to do Q&A later on,
I should probably get all questions
that involve multi book series
and how to write them and
all questions having to do
with actual stuff involving
combat should-
>> So you two have read the
book, so how true do you think
that Michael made the
characters to your experience?
>> She has not read the book.
>> Oh.
>> She's top of her class and
I'm like the kid in the back
that forgot to read the book.
[ Laughter ]
>> She's waiting for the
Cliff Notes to come out.
>> Yeah.
>> I was like, tell me a
little bit about the book.
>> You should have
gotten a synopsis.
You know you can go
on Google and do that.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> I read them because then I
know what my students have read,
whether they've read the
book or the synopsis.
[ Laughter ]
>> I'm terrible in history so I
will not judge any historical-
>> That's probably good.
>> I have no yeah, but we were
talking a little bit before
and I thought the characters were
very well captured and especially
on the way from day one they
start off at training until hey,
we've now been through some
stuff and now we're a family
that transitioned through that,
I think is very well done.
I was laughing at, there's a point
that I think it's Rainy that's
getting on the train ready to leave
and they're looking at the train
station and she notices it's weird
because the guys were saying goodbye
to the girls as they're going off
to war and I chuckled because last
Christmas my roommate and one or two
of the other girls on the ship with
me, and there are far more girls now
than there were when I started off,
this last cruise we actually
had quite a bit and you'd go
in the bathroom and like, I
have to wait to take a shower?
This is new, I've never
had this problem before.
>> It's a good thing,
it's a good thing.
>> It's nice that, way easier to
have a girl's night out now so,
but the boys had actually come out
to visit the girls at Christmas
and when they had come back they
said it was a really weird dynamic
because the boys literally said
goodbye to the girls and got
in a taxi and went back to the
airport and the girls went back off
to war and that it was almost a
mirror image of the two scenes.
I think things like that were
captured very well and a lot
of the little bit of razzing
that goes back and forth
in the transition between I don't
really care where you come from
or who you are as long
as you do your job well,
and we did it together that
becomes, that matters more
in the end then your
roots and if you're a girl
or a guy or what race you are.
I thought that was pretty cool.
>> Well, thanks.
>> I think it's interesting too
like, when I interviewed one
of the first women Rangers to
graduate from Ranger school
and I don't know if you guys know
the combat exclusion rule for women
in combat, even though women have
been there World War II like,
I've interviewed women
Veterans who I remember going
to VA there was a little old woman
there and she was like, "Yeah,
I served" and you don't
hear a lot of those stories.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> But I interviewed one of
the first women to graduate
from Ranger school and she said
the same thing, when you're dirty,
and tired, and hungry,
and you need someone
to carry a little bit more
weight, you do not care what
that person looks like,
what their nationality is,
where they're from, or
what their gender is.
You just want someone that's
going to be there for you and kind
of have your back,
which is interesting.
When you're exhausted you just
don't care what that person looks
like that's next to you, you know?
>> Well, the military
really is a family you know,
and that's the feeling
I get wherever we go.
I think it is just
such a special family.
>> And it can be very dysfunctional
at times too [laughter] you know,
like you have brothers in
your family who I always say
if you're a woman you have to just
learn to deal with you're going
to listen to every sports fact that
there possibly is on the planet,
you're going to hear guys arguing
about cars, and this and that,
and it really is being surrounded by
an incredible group of men and women
but brothers that you, I'm sure you
guys have brothers that you love
and brothers that drive you insane.
That to me has always
been what the military is.
It's a wonderful family but family
can drive you insane too [laughter].
>> Sure.
>> For the record, we
used to say that the guys
in my squadron talked more about
hair and fashion than the girls did.
>> Yes.
>> We had more discussions on who
could come up, Fury had just come
out and they all wanted
the Brad Pitt haircut
and they would go spend an hour at
Zara when we pulled into port and me
and my friend were just
like, "What are you doing?"
We're like, "That should be us."
>> Of course it should be pointed
out in World War II things
were substantially different
in that the Army was segregated,
segregated openly racist
and I've masked the "N"
word throughout the book not
because I didn't want to because
I don't like masking anything,
but it would have been an
imposition on the librarians
who have a very hard time stocking
the book as a result but racism
at that time wasn't under the radar.
It was right out there and open.
People would tell you to your
face, people would say any number
of things, anti-Semitism, racism,
and those play parts around my book
and also the sexism
would have been obvious
but I felt it would have a
different character to it.
>> Uh huh.
>> Because I think people acquire
kind of a vocabulary of hate.
They learn how to hate, they
learn how to express thoughts
that are racist, or sexist,
misogynist, but in 1942,
that wouldn't have happened yet.
>> Absolutely.
>> Because women were not yet
liberated and men were not
yet feeling threatened by
women in the workplace,
that came after World War
II after they realized oh,
that riveting job I used to have,
turns out my wife does
it just as well as I do.
So yeah, at that point
the Army was very much
that Black units were not allowed
in combat until the very end.
>> Did you realize that?
Did most of you realize that?
>> Yeah so one of the two
changes I made in the book I mean,
in addition to inserting women into
it I moved the combat involvement
of African-American units
earlier than they were in fact,
because for fictional reasons
I needed it to be that way
because I had a character
I needed to get in play.
Other than that, I tried
to stay very accurate
and I've had people say, gotten
reviews of it saying well,
really you were unsparing in your
treatment of racism and misogyny
and I wrote back to one person, "No,
actually I probably dialed it back
by 25 or 30 percent, it would
have been worse I think."
>> Yeah, so for those of you
who have not read the book,
there are three female characters
so Rio is sort of the I don't know,
sort of the sassy one would you say?
>> She's the all American
girl basically.
She's actually based in my head
on Audie Murphy, who was a guy
and I use Audie Murphy
for a specific reason.
Audie Murphy, if you don't
know, Audie Murphy was a soldier
in World War II who tried to
enlist, who was a kid from Texas.
His parents I think were dead, he
was living with his sister and went
and tried to enlist in the Marines
because he thought they
were the biggest, baddest.
Are they the biggest and baddest?
>> No, no.
>> This guy right down here-
[ Laughter ]
>> He's got a whole different
opinion on it, just saying.
[ Laughter ]
>> He tried to enlist in the
Marines and they told him go away
because you're too small and
you look kind of effeminate,
you look kind of like a girl.
He went to the Navy and they
told him exactly the same thing
and he finally got in the Army, the
Army trained him, sent him to Italy,
he was deployed and even after he
was deployed his officers didn't
want to let him get to the front
line because he was a tiny,
little guy and looked kind of
effeminate from their point of view.
He was in fact, five feet, five
inches tall and weighed 110 pounds,
which is almost exactly the size
of the average American woman today
and Audie Murphy, for those
of you who don't know,
is the most decorated soldier in
the American forces in World War II.
He won basically every medal you
can get including the big one
so that's who Rio is.
>> And the Rainy was another
character and she was a Jewish woman
and so she went in to
fight against the Germans
and really had this strong
passion that all she wanted
to do was kill Nazis and so-
>> She's the only one of the three
who really has what you would think
of as a classic motivation, I
want to go to war to kill people.
Rio is very much swept along
and the reason I did that was
because when I was doing
research and listening
to first person narratives
you'd hear guys say it
over and over again.
I didn't go to save the world,
I didn't go for this or that,
I just felt like I had to,
I felt like I was swept up,
I felt like it was time,
my friends were going,
and so there was that kind of feel.
A lot of the guys who enlisted,
and I assume the same would be true
of Rio, she enlisted
because her friend was.
>> And to avenge her sister's death.
>> And to avenge, yeah and
she had a personal motive
because she had a sister die
and though is much hipper.
She's a big city girl, she comes
from New York City, she's Jewish,
she knows that Jewish families
have already started kind
of to get the feeling that hey,
we're not getting a lot of letters
from the relatives in Poland,
I wonder what that's about,
so it was already beginning to
settle into the Jewish community
that this was something specifically
heinous going on for Jews.
Of course they knew obviously about
the Nuremberg laws by that point
and then Frangie Marr is just in it
basically because her dad got hurt-
>> And she's African-American.
>> Yeah, she's a Black girl from-
>> Small, terrible soldier right?
>> Yeah, she's a terrible
soldier but she wants-
>> [Laughter] You made her
out to be a terrible soldier.
>> But she wants to be a
medic and she's from Tulsa
and I used Tulsa deliberately
and for people who don't know
about Tulsa, I would urge you to
learn some of the history of Tulsa
because it's not great but it's an
interesting sideline that gets woven
in later on in the
narrative so yeah, yeah,
three main characters
and a couple of others.
>> And Frangie went in
because they needed the money,
they were very poor.
>> Yeah, her dad was out of work.
He'd been injured and
for practical reasons,
which is again another
big motivation
from people especially
in those days.
This was a poor country, we were
just getting over the Depression.
There was a lot of people for whom
not much money was a lot of money.
Ten dollars was the difference
between you keep your
house or you don't.
Different now, now
it's a hundred dollars.
>> So she had to go in
to support her family.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> She was helping to
support her family.
>> She was helping,
she needs the paycheck.
>> So that's why she went in.
>> Yeah.
>> So then your next books
will be the three stories
of where the three women end up?
>> Yeah, I'm going
to stick with them
so I've already written book two.
That's in the can, in other
words I've written it,
it's been edited and
I'm done with it.
It goes from the invasion
of Sicily up through Italy
and then book three, which will
be D-Day through the liberation
of [inaudible] and probably
some aftermath depending
on how bloated the damned
thing is by that point
and what my editor is
telling me in terms of length.
She doesn't like books
over 500 pages.
>> So when you started out, did you
think there are some things I want
to get off my chest, or some
themes I want to reveal?
>> No, I never do that.
>> No?
>> And it's odd because my
books are generally considered,
I spend a lot of time talking
about philosophy, about ideas,
and about abstractions and God knows
in real life I'm a huge egomaniac
but in my books, I don't want
to be present in the books.
I don't want people to see me.
I want them to just look at the
characters and if there are ideas
that come out then I want to
present them as fairly as I can.
I've had people ask me again
and again are you Christian,
are you atheist because
they don't know,
because I've discussed
religion repeatedly in my books
and I've tried to be fair
to all sides of the topic.
It's not my job as I see it,
to force my ideas on readers.
My job is to tell a story
and if in the process
of me telling a story that's
entertaining they reach a conclusion
or think about something,
that's great.
>> All right well stylistically, I'm
an English teacher so when you talk
to the reader and you
say gentle reader,
that sort of threw me off a little
bit so where did that come from?
>> That's an old form that you'd
see back more in Victorian era.
>> Right, exactly.
>> So I did that deliberately
as kind of a throwback
because it's meant to sound ironic.
It's meant to sound a little bit, I
don't know a little sneering almost.
Not quite but you know,
a little bit of,
it's a bit of that you don't know
what's going on, I'm telling you
so there's narrator who we don't
know the identity of the narrator.
>> Right.
>> Who has just a couple of
bits scattered throughout.
>> Will you reveal that?
>> Oh yeah, yeah.
At first I didn't know
who it was [laughter]
because I don't plan books,
I make them up every day
as I go along although in
this case you know, Mr. Hitler
and Mr. Churchill kind of wrote the
script and now I'm following along.
Spoiler alert, we still
win [laughter].
>> Are there any comments that you
would like to make to the audience?
Any of our-
>> And we'll do questions, we're
going to do questions right?
You guys have questions?
If you don't , we're just
going to sit here and stare
at each other [laughter].
Yeah, yeah you.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> What inspired me?
I've got to tell you the
truth, I never think about the,
I never look at it as inspiration.
I don't treat this, and part
of the reason is I think writers get
a little over themselves you know,
get a little full of themselves
sometimes and start talking
about inspiration and start talking
about opening a vein and bleeding
on a page and all this stuff,
he says cleaning up his language
at the last second [laughter].
That's not my approach.
My approach is this is my job.
I go do my job every day so before
I became a writer I'd been a waiter
for 10 years.
Matter of fact, Annapolis, Maryland,
you ever go to Middleton's?
>> Yes.
>> Middleton Tavern?
>> Love it.
>> I used to wait tables
at Middleton Tavern.
I was a waiter for 10 years,
I cleaned toilets with my wife
for two years, we had a janitorial
service and so that's where I come
from and I look at this as this
is my job, I work hard at it,
I get up every day and I do
it, I don't tolerate this talk
of writer's block or
any of this nonsense.
It's my job to get up and do it
and by the way, when I say job,
it's the best job in the world.
>> Oh yes, tell us where you write.
Okay, listen.
>> Well at the present, I'm
writing mostly on my deck,
which is on the side of a hill
looking out over San Francisco Bay
so I sit there and look at there's
the city and there's this much
of the Golden Gate over
here, I can see it sticking
up over Belvedere Island
and then there's Alcatraz
and all this other kind of stuff
so I go out there and I work
for about three hours a day,
drinking coffee and smoking cigars.
Don't smoke cigars [laughter].
>> Yeah, yeah
>> You can drink coffee.
Don't, you'll look ridiculous
with a cigar, seriously.
It's like, the best job in the
world and as I sometimes point
out to audiences, I generally
earn more than the President
of the United States and nobody
calls me up at 3:00 in the morning
to tell me something blew
up somewhere, you know?
>> So writing is a great profession.
>> It's great man, if you
can make a living at it,
it's the best thing in the world.
If people knew how easy
it is and how great it is,
we'd have people [laughter],
we don't want to tell them.
What they do is way harder.
They have to fly airplanes.
>> I want to know what's
the theme of your story.
>> The theme?
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know, did a
teacher put you up to that?
Where are you?
[ Laughter ]
>> Right there?
Is that a-
>> What's wrong with themes?
You know I'm a teacher right?
>> I don't know.
Look, I look at these things,
for me I follow certain very
simple rules on writing.
The first is, it's always character,
everything else is subordinate
to character so if you're, are
you thinking about being a writer?
>> Uh-uh.
>> Okay, you don't want
to do that [laughter].
For people who are
thinking about it,
job number one is make
your characters real,
make them authentic
and that's how I start.
I start with character, then I
go to setting, and from then on,
I just make stuff up but I never
really sit down and think oh,
what's the theme of this.
It's not like that.
>> But when you read you should
think, what is the theme of this?
[ Laughter ]
>> Right here, dude.
>> How long does it take
you to write a book?
>> How long does it
take me to write a book?
This one took me about six months.
Usually it takes me
about six months.
>> It's pretty thick.
>> I write two books a year usually.
>> How long did it take
you to write your book?
>> One month.
[ Laughter ]
>> Revised answer.
>> It's still six months yeah,
dude, other dude right there.
>> Out of all the books
that you have written,
which one is your favorite?
>> My favorite is always the last
one that I've written successfully
so I'm very fond of the Gone series
because that basically pays the
bills but I'm happy with this one.
I'm glad I pulled it off,
I'm glad I didn't screw it
up because I've written 150
books and I've got to tell you,
you would think by
now that when I sit
down to write a book I'd be
like, all Mr. Confidence,
I know what I'm doing and
that's so not the case.
I start every single time and
sit there and I'm a few pages in
and I go, everybody is going
to realize what a fake I am,
everybody is going to realize
I don't have any talent,
I don't know what I'm doing.
This obviously makes no sense,
no part of this is good.
And then at some point in there,
I'll flip to the other side and go,
my God, I'm a genius,
look at this [laughter].
This is amazing.
And then I finally send it off to
my editor and as soon as I hit send
on the email I'm like, oh God, it's
a piece of crap, it's terrible.
It's the same cycle
each time dude you know.
That's the way it is.
Okay, we've got to go to-
>> Miss Kristen, why do
you think that you stuck
to astronaut since you were little?
>> Can you say that again?
Sorry.
>> Why do you think you stuck
to being an astronaut
since you were little?
>> Um, I got lucky in that I
happened to know what I wanted to do
and along the way I didn't
find anything that I wanted
to do more I guess, so I know a
lot of friends who fly with me know
who didn't start out wanting to fly.
They just followed a path
and they end up there.
I will say that I'll never
be an astronaut at this point
but it definitely got me
to where I needed to be
and at this point I really think
that the military for me is kind
of a calling and I love everything
about it except maybe really bad
nights in the weather trying to land
on a moving ship but
that's a different story.
I think somebody, I was just reading
a blog from a current astronaut
and he said you know, I have
a bunch of friends who set
out to be an astronaut and that's
all they cared about the entire way
and they were so focused on that
they forgot to enjoy the journey
and forgot to do what they wanted to
do along the way so I definitely say
that for all you guys as you
go through school and college
and start getting jobs,
do what you want to do.
Have a goal but don't make
that be only focus in your life
so for me right now, flying
jets has been awesome.
I haven't found anything I want to
do more yet so I'm going to stick
with it for a little while until
they fire me so I think looking back
on it, the journey has definitely
been the best part of that
and wanting to be an
astronaut got me to that point
so I'm thankful it's
something that I did stick
with because it got me
to where I am today.
Does that answer your question?
Cool.
>> It's a great message,
enjoy the journey.
>> What was your favorite
part of writing the book?
>> My favorite part?
Well, I actually kind of
got to I like the research
so I've been really straining
to try to make this as accurate
as possible even though I'm
obviously not a historian
or a high school graduate.
>> You are.
>> I know.
>> Now you are.
>> Well now I am, that's
right, you're right.
The research part was actually
kind of fun and fun in strange sort
of ways like for example, I
wanted to be super accurate
so when I was talking about the
girls were learning how to fire,
well the girls and the guys were
all learning how to fire the M1
and windage and elevation,
so that part I was able
to find the original video online
that the Army produced in 1942,
and so I just lifted big
sections of dialogue straight
across because I was
determined to be accurate.
But also, you get to do
weird, cool stuff like I drove
around Sicily just looking at
stuff going okay, if I was walking
if I wasn't in this car, how
much harder would that be?
What's the slope like?
What can I see from here,
what can I see from there?
That's all kind of neat.
I went down to Las Vegas
where they allow you
to fire all the weapons well,
not all the weapons obviously,
the handguns and the
infantry weapons M1, 45, BAR,
and got to fire all those just
because I wanted to be accurate
about how they feel, how
they sound, the little stuff
like is there muzzle flash at the
end of a Thompson sub-machine gun?
Yes, that kind of stuff so
that kind of stuff was all fun.
I enjoyed that.
>> If you live through the
characters then it's kind
of interesting that you wrote
about women because you're a man.
>> I am, yeah.
>> So finding that voice I
mean, it has to be unusual
to see a woman's perspective
I think.
>> No and I'll tell you why and
I don't want to get too heavy
or serious about this but we have
this assumption that we're dealing
with people as a class
of people, as a group
but if you're writing character,
you're writing a specific individual
so it's like saying the
body of women are X. Well,
that says absolutely nothing
about one individual woman.
If the body of men are such
and such, the entire population
of Black people, the entire
population of Latino's,
you can't extrapolate from
that and conclude anything
about a single individual.
You can however, you
write about the individual
but I've also got a lot of practice.
My wife is an author, Katherine
Applegate, The One and Only Ivan,
we wrote a lot of books together and
as I work with her on many, many,
many books like, literally 100,
I've to this day written more books
as a woman than I have as a man.
>> Have you really?
>> In fact, I'm the guy who-
>> That's interesting.
>> When Jessica and
Elizabeth Wakefield
in Sweet Valley Twins got
their first period [laughter]-
>> Oh my God.
>> Yeah.
>> Probably some of the kids don't
know what that means [laughter].
>> You see how young
they are, right?
[ Laughter ]
>> It's a form of punctuation.
>> Yes, perfect.
>> The British say full stop.
>> Okay, I think we're
going to take one question.
I think Sasha, you had somebody
standing in line with you?
One final question.
>> How many books have
you written in total?
>> Well we think it's about 150.
It's hard to count them all because
some of them we were ghost writing
for somebody else, some of the
ones we created were ghost written
for us, sometimes we've
had series that we started
that were then perpetuated
by other writers but in terms
of what we actually sat down
and did this with, typed with,
we think it's about
150 give or take.
>> Do you know what he
means by ghost written?
>> Yeah, ghost written is
when you do all the work
but the other person gets
the credit [laughter].
By the way, this is a
concept totally unknown
in the military I'm sure.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yeah we call it every day.
>> No you do, that's like
there's an author of record
who supposedly writes the books
but then they're actually written
by somebody else and we were
the somebody else in many cases
for a while, my wife and I.
>> I hate to interrupt
this amazing conversation
but we have more things coming so I
first want to thank our participants
on the stage, Kristen,
Rebecca, Michael and Dr. Biden.
[ Applause ]
>> And David Mao and
John Cole as well.
Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.